Speaker 1: Within hours of the firing of Tucker
Carlson failed, former President Donald Trump was
interviewed on Newsmax. This is an interview as
confused as I have ever seen. Donald Trump. One
of the first things he was asked about was his
opinion on the firing of Tucker. And what's,
of course, very funny about this is that we
now know Tucker hates Trump. Tucker's text
messages revealed and the discovery process of
that Dominion lawsuit, which ultimately led to
a nearly $800 million settlement. There
was this text message where Tucker said,
I hate Trump passionately, and I can't wait
until we can stop talking about him. So Trump,
of course, knows that. But I think Trump still
realizes that, at least in some sense, he may
need an ally in Tucker Carlson for his primary
and for his eventual general election campaign
if he gets there. So here is Trump reacting to
the departure, a.k.a. firing of Tucker from Fox.
Speaker 2: So Tucker Carlson was sitting here
two weeks ago interviewing you. He's gone. What
do you make of that?
Speaker 4: Well,
I'm shocked. I'm surprised. He's a very good
person, a very good man and very talented, as
you know. And he had very high ratings. So we're
just learning about it almost as we speak now.
Speaker 1: A couple people wrote to me and there's
more to this, which we'll look at saying, you
know, David. If you read the expression on Trump's
face this little smirk. Trump is saying one thing,
but projecting another one with the smirk. And
that's Trump's reaction, which is Tucker got what
was coming to him because he said bad things about
me in those text messages. It's an interpretation.
I don't know. You make of it what you will.
Speaker 4: You know, I just said, wow,
that was something. That's a big one. I don't
know if it was voluntary or was it somebody fired.
But I think Tucker's been terrific. He's been
especially over the last year or so. He's been
terrific to me. There's a lot of turmoil over
there on Fox. I mean, 787, they just paid. Why
would they get rid of a guy who's performing?
Why would somebody do that to their business?
Speaker 2: Because they're losing money
right now. Their stock has gone down.
Speaker 4: Well, I was surprised that they
made a settlement on that case. I thought
that was a case that should easily be won and
they made a settlement. Look, you have to ask
them. I'm not I'm not representing them at all
by any by any means. But the Tucker situation,
again, you don't know if it's a firing.
Maybe he left because he wasn't being
given his free rein. He wants free rein, maybe.
Speaker 1: But now, of course, we know that Tucker
was indeed fired and we know that there were many
problems. Tucker's coverage partially responsible
for the lawsuit that led to the settlement, Tucker
saying horrible things about Fox management in
text messages released as part of that lawsuit.
Tucker currently sued for having a discriminatory,
misogynistic, sexist, racist production
apparatus and potentially another lawsuit
coming from Ray up. So Fox News realized,
at least to some degree, that Tucker became
a problem for them. Continuing on this very
confusing Newsmax interview we saw, DeSantis
asked by HANNITY about Trump. Now we see Trump
asked by Greg Kelly about DeSantis, and Trump
takes a different approach than DeSantis did.
Speaker 2: Want to get to Nixon in a moment.
By the way, Ron DeSantis, do you think he could
be a good president someday in like eight years,
six years? I mean, you endorsed him once. He's
got some talent, you're kind of crushing him
right now. Someday, could he be president?
Speaker 4: Well, I endorsed him once and he
was losing badly. And because of the endorsement,
he won in a landslide. The following literally
the following day. Look, right now, I'm very
down on him. I'm a believer in loyalty and I'm
a believer in other things. And he has
obviously not run a very good campaign
because he's getting he's getting crushed.
Speaker 1: So I understand that there is no
campaign yet. That's the most interesting thing
about this. Trump is acting as though DeSantis
is running a campaign now. You could argue.
Well, he sort of is, but he hasn't announced
because he's feeling it out. Okay. It's not
actually a campaign. And there's a question
as to if and how the dynamics will change.
Speaker 4: I really don't know. I don't know.
You know, I don't know him that well. I agreed to
endorse him. He came over to see me. He was one
of 100 people that fought a little bit on the
impeachment hoax number one. Impeachment Hoax
number two, they were hoaxes. They were just
hoaxes. And based on that, I did it because I
didn't know the people he was running. He was
running against a man that was way up in the
polls, leading by a massive amount. That election
was over when I endorsed him. The election was
over in Ryan's favor. I mean, it was Ron was
getting ready to quit. So I don't know. I am very
disappointed in him because I'm a loyal person.
Speaker 1: Maybe that's really what this is all
about. He could have just skip to that.
Speaker 4: To a fault. I'm a loyal person
and somebody gets you into office
and then you're telling people, Well,
I don't know if I'll run against
the president, you know, I mean,
life shouldn't have to work that way.
Speaker 1: And there it is. The anecdote
I regularly refer to, which is DeSantis was
asked, Would you rule out running against Trump?
And he didn't rule it out. Trump remembers Trump
bringing up that anecdote. He has not forgotten
about that The topic of the January six riots
came up, as it often does, and listen to what
Trump had to say. This This is really wild stuff.
Speaker 4: They're weaponizing law enforcement at
a level that nobody's ever seen before, and
it's very dangerous for the country. And our
country is not going to stand for. You know,
we have very strong people in this country
and they've been sitting back and watching.
They've been watching. They've watched that
whole situation at the Capitol. They didn't
walk in with guns. They shot Ashli Babbitt.
That officer bad thing should happen to him. He
shot her and she was totally defenseless. She was
like an American patriot. You look at her.
Speaker 1: She was a patriot. Listen.
That's been investigated. And it's interesting to
continue to hear the people who say, we support
the police, we defend the police, etc., etc., all
of a sudden say, hey, even though there was an
extensive investigation into the death of Ashli
Babbitt and the officer was found not at fault.
They insist that the officer did something wrong.
Why is that? It's because that principle of we
support the police only when it's convenient.
Speaker 4: Don't align the flag and the whole
thing. She was an American patriot. They
shot her and nothing happened to him. If
that were the other way around, there would
have been hell to pay. But the people of this
country just aren't going to take it anymore.
Speaker 1: Well, I don't know exactly what Trump
means by that. Is he alluding to violence? Is
he alluding to how people will vote? We never
know. Last clip, Donald Trump asked about
his former attorney general, William Barr.
Gets a little dicey.
Speaker 4: And most of my
people were smart and tough. I had some bad ones.
I mean, I wish I had a better attorney general,
somebody that was tougher, that wasn't afraid to
fight. He should have been fighting instead of
being afraid to be impeached. She was petrified
of being impeached, just petrified. It made him
just a couple of words I could use. I would
never use the word impotent, of course, but
it made him absolutely useless when it came
to election fraud and so many other things.
And now he sits back and he pontificates with,
you know, some some of these various shows that
are on. I wish I had a better attorney general.
Speaker 1: Well, remember, Trump ran on I will
hire the absolute best people. And so by his
own standards, if there is anybody to blame for
William Barr, it is Trump himself. So this is
what I expect to continue in terms of DeSantis
versus Trump, whether or not listen, even if
DeSantis doesn't announce until the point at
which DeSantis says, I'm not running, if that is
what is coming, this is what we're going to see.
We are going to see Trump continuing to attack the
Centers for Disloyalty and DeSantis playing the
I'm too good for this. I'm too classy for this.
I'm above it thing, which only makes him look
weak to the average Republican voter. We will have
more. We're going to take a quick break. Lindsey
Graham had his bubble popped on CNN yesterday
and many other things to discuss with you.